You are listening to radio lab radio from W.
N y. S. T. E. N. N. P. R.
F. I guess my first question is like what?
What conceivable set of circumstances led to you doing what you did?
I just thought it would be a weird thing to do. Oh yeah. Yeah. Was like,
well that would be weird. We don't know if it's funny, but we try it out.
So yeah. Is it going to be weird? We'll do it. Yeah. Is it going to alien?
Had half the audience? Yeah,
you are. So,
okay, wait, just to set things up,
you'd better cause two people that you just heard your wrist and show Kurt
Brown. Oh, hello.
They are comedians. That's it.
And we first heard about the bit you're about to hear, uh, from Jesse Thorn.
Yes. Host of the sound of young America. Great show. Are you rolling over there,
Jesse? No, let me record you. Okay. Check
from my phone. Okay. Yeah, I'm rolling.
So you said that when Kurt and Kristen walk on stage, what happens? Well,
there's a cuddle of jokes up top. You know, they joke about this,
this TV show that they hosted in the 70s uncle Ben's farmyard courthouse.
I explained the American judicial system using a court house,
made completely of animals, was canceled immediately,
and so the audience is kind of laughing at the jokes, but thinking like, oh,
this is going to be a regular comedy sketch sketch from it tonight. All right.
Hey, Harrigan. Ready? I'm ready. Okay,
well then they go into this song.
Oh, okay. Tom
[inaudible]
does this maniacal singing, clapping.
Christine is doing this. Horsey dance.
Oh
Wow.
It's, can you do this in like why
Haitian Jad when we do it, we like at the, after the third rep,
my last name, they get it like, oh,
they could just going to do that over and over
and then somewhere around like four AV around the fourth time.
Then it's not really not funny. I use this quiet.
They're like, I'm done with that. I'm done. I don't want to watch this anymore.
Why are they still doing it? And then,
and then that changes to actual hatred and they're like,
you stupid people, you to stupid people,
but somewhere between like nine and 11
and they then they're like, oh,
I like this.
[inaudible] did you get this next level?
Which is they can't continue doing this and then they do continue doing it.
Okay, but it could, they really, their eyes are starting to cross by that point.
I'm dripping sweat. Kristen's angry that I've gone that long.
I mean,
you can hear a curb in that thing like losing track of the song because he's
going into some kind of [inaudible].
Okay. Have had her on stage whisper,
stop it. Walk in my
[inaudible].
This is maybe my favorite thing in the history of the world.
What I love about it is that your brain is trying to make it into what you want
it to be, which is a joke, but there is no joke happening.
And so what these two people are doing is creating the expectation that the
expectation is going to be broken,
but then breaking that expectation that the expectation is going to be broken by
just delivering the thing that they've been delivering over and over for the
past 10 minutes. What's the longest
taking it? 10 minutes in Australia because you were drunk? Yeah,
it seemed like it seemed like 10 minutes. We can't be sure if it was 10 minutes.
It seems like there's no way it's 10 minutes. What?
It was 10 minutes and the audience went crazy.
No, [inaudible]
just in Charlotte as a whole. Kristen Schaal is a Ho.
You look at her desk, look at her, go look good. Her Dad's like, Oh
hey, I'm Chad. Boom. Rod's in Charlotte. I'm Robert Krulwich Dad.
This is radio lab and today, oh, today it's all about loops.
Things
that happen over and over and over and over and over and over and over and over.
Coming up. Lipstick hurt. You stream loops in here.
You in juice loops that scare you.
Loops and loops and loops that incomplete you
at what? Kristen's
a
[inaudible].
So where, where are you guys? What, where in San Francisco? San Francisco,
or if you're not in Texas, no, just sounds like we're in Texas.
She's from Texas. So like can you guys actually just a, if you don't mind,
introduce yourself so we know just could we have your name and all that?
I'm Mary Sue Campbell. I live in Novato, California,
and my daughter Christine is 30 years old.
I live in San Francisco. Um,
and I was raised in Nevada in the house that said this wouldn't happen.
That shall we begin. Okay.
Tell me the beginning how the story starts from the beginning. Uh,
I, it was odd.
Christine actually called me Tuesday morning about 10 o'clock and just said, oh,
what are you doing mom? And I said, Oh,
I'm just gonna go out in the yard and do some yard work and lend some errands.
And she said, well,
you ought to do the yard work early because it's going to be hot today.
So we're in the, we're in the summertime. It was summertime. Yeah,
it was August, August 24th and apparently what, 10 minutes later,
half an hour later, she's said, I called her,
she had left me a voicemail, something like, Hey Christine, it's mom.
Something's, something's not right. Something's wrong.
I need you to call me back. So I gave her a call back and,
and she said something, thinking about the house isn't right.
There's things look weird in here. What's weird? W what are you talking about?
And then she said, well, I'm looking at the calendar and it says August,
2010 and I'm like, uh Huh. She's like,
well that's not right. And I said, well,
yes it is August 24th,
2010 and as soon as I said that out loud, I grabbed my purse
to leave. Oh my God, she's had a stroke. That was my, my,
my first reaction. And um, oh, that makes me feel emotional.
And so Christine says she walked out of her house to the car,
keeping your mom on the phone. What else do you see?
I'm just trying to keep her talking to me. All the while,
her mom's telling her one thing after another just doesn't look right.
She says there's a strange black truck on the driveway,
which is the truck that belongs to her boyfriend that has been parked there for
10 years. So I'm of course, increasingly, I mean,
I'm just freaking out at this point.
So she hangs up with her mom and then calls the paramedics. Medics
and I, half an hour later, Christine arrived at the hospital.
By the time I walked in, she had been there for five or 10 minutes at the most,
and as soon as I walked in, the doctor greeted me and said, said, uh,
this is her, Dr Jonathan Vallejo's Christine. It's immediately evident.
It's not a stroke, not an infection. That's, that's a huge relief. But I said,
your mother has, has transient, Global Amnesia,
fancy and global transients global. How do those words hit you?
I'll be honest with you. I had no idea what that meant.
I think the word I heard the most is amnesia.
Your mother has lost her ability to form new memories.
I mean she can't remember, but if it's not going to last forever, um,
it usually lasts between one and 24 hours and we're not sure what causes it.
And it's at this point where the story goes from something kind of frightening
to something a little more surreal. Yeah. So when I came in, um,
her mother is sitting up in bed,
she's a smiler and she immediately started asking questions. Okay,
so what's the date? I said, well, it's Tuesday, August 24th. Yes.
And of course we have a video on youtube of this. My birthday's already past.
Yep. Do you remember if I remember that?
I'm trying to remember the last date. I remember. I don't remember if my breath,
yeah. Wait, we hung out.
You came over to my house and we watched a video that I made for you when I was
in Texas and all of your sisters and some of your brothers said happy birthday
to you on video. Yeah. But we still have the videos that you can watch it again,
but you're going to remember eventually they say it's just temporary.
Where was that? It was at home. You were at home? Yep.
You're at home doing some gardening and you called me and you're feeling
confused. So I called the paramedics had been come and get you.
And then we came here. Did you have two tests on you? Okay, so what's the date?
August 24th it's Tuesday.
I'm trying to remember the last day I remember. Yeah,
I don't remember my birthday. Do you remember your birthday? Yeah. Yeah.
That must've just been recently. Yeah, couple weeks ago.
Now you might have missed it,
but this conversation they're having just started over this August because every
90 seconds Mary Sue's memory resets.
August 24th what's strange is the repetition,
like we started that last clip you heard with her saying this,
trying to remember the last day, Dan,
remember 90 seconds later after her memory resets, she says,
try to remember the bias of date. I remember 90 seconds later, I'm trying.
I don't remember the last damn remember.
And as you watched this video for a few minutes,
you realize what's happening here. Is that Mary sue? You're right, Dan Week.
It is. No, it's in a loop.
And it goes like this first the date. So what's the date?
August 24th she then responds in almost the same way every time,
like birthdays. She's missed her birthday. Yeah.
And every time she says that, darn in exactly the same way. If you fast forward,
it's already past my birthday though. Yeah.
She must enjoy her birthday quite a bit. You're going to remember it eventually.
Then she laughs. Hey, what happened?
Then they recapped you working in the garden and you gave me a call.
Christine explains the whole thing.
It's usually when she says the word paramedics called the paramedics right there
and have them come and pick you up.
The Mary Sue's eyes get really wide and this look of sheer,
utter disbelief. Yes. Yeah. Isn't that creepy? I mean,
every single you say that, isn't that creepy? Creepy.
90 seconds later is some creepy 90 seconds later
and it's softening this point right after creepy [inaudible] the two sets.
Okay. So I don't know. Tuesday,
like somebody put it on rewind over and over and over again. Okay.
Yes.
Add repeated the birthday so much that the nerves apparently was behind me
mouthing the words. Yeah. Oh, that's my birthday. Yeah.
It's like groundhog day in here. Groundhog's Day,
like every two minutes we're doing a list. The same thing. Yes, we do that.
We have had the same conversation over and over again.
Every two minutes for the last two and a half hours. Two and a half hours.
No, I think
we can't seem to talk about anything else.
That is what we're talking about today.
What Day of the week is it? Tuesday, August 24th
you didn't miss it. You were there. Yeah, I'm watching it.
I wanted to slap me. You know,
I wanted to reach out and slap me and say damn it.
I just told you that for the record. Yeah. I would never slept with my mom.
I would not. No, she would not. Okay, so I'll be quiet. Here is a clear,
this is a person who's lost her memory. Yeah,
but why would her behavior from one cycle to the next be so precisely and
consistently the same? I mean sometimes exactly the same. Yeah. Why?
I think what it is is one of the things the nurses said is that when you have
something like this, your true self comes out.
Your true, the word true is interesting. So yeah.
Is that what we're seeing on that video? Is that your true person,
your true self? Oh yeah. I mean that's my mom through and through right there.
I mean, she's, what Christine means is not the repetition,
but that her mom keeps asking so many questions, inquisitive.
She just wants to know what's going on with, with all sorts of, you know,
across the board. I love problems. I love puzzles.
Are you like a Sudoku fiend? You know, I am. I am. I hate to admit this,
God, I play Escape Room Games on the Internet escape room.
What are those?
They're stupid little games where they have little hidden pixels that you find
you're, you're stuck in a room and you have to get out.
You've got to find the key to the door and there's all these little hidden
places. Oh, this is the perfect metaphor. Oh yeah.
I was my own escape room
Tuesday. There's a different way of seeing this. First of all,
Jonathan blow that er doctor who's seen a bunch of these cases, he said, well,
that puzzler instinct, that's not just Mary sue.
What everybody does is struggle over and over again with where am I and when am
I. It's just the brain in survival mode. And another thing that everybody does,
and he's seen about six of these patients so far, is that everybody,
not just Mary sue,
but everybody becomes a broken record right down to the,
the phrasing of the sentences, which keeps them out a little bit.
It makes, you know,
it makes the brain seem a little bit more like a machine. You know,
you give the machine the exact same set of inputs every 90 seconds,
give it the same doctor, the same hospital room,
same beeping machines and see if the output ever varies.
And it does,
it almost seems like the patient has no free. Well,
uh,
and so sometimes in the back of his head he thinks, God,
if I had that condition and someone videotape me, I would love to see, uh,
see my own tape. Why, you know, I think, uh,
I want to see, could I somehow escape the loop? Huh? Or,
or would I, would I had to up end up with the rest of us?
Now, thankfully, according to Jonathan,
what normally happens in this condition is that as time goes on,
that 92nd Luke starts to slowly expand.
It's actually more like two minutes or three minutes. Eventually four minutes.
Now it's five minutes. And for Mary Sue,
after a few hours as her loop got longer and longer,
her old memories started to creep back in. By that evening,
she was remembering up until um, like that Sunday, few hours later,
her memory began to extend into Monday morning.
By the time we left the hospital, she remembered Monday night. And then finally,
so we begin. Okay. Tell me the beginning, how the story starts.
I, it was odd.
Christine actually called me Tuesday morning about 10 o'clock and just said, oh,
what are you doing mom? And apparently 10 minutes later,
hour later,
I'm Robert Krulwich. I'm Jad Abumrad man, we'll be right back.